jeux sont là partout autour de nos qu'il
veille sur vous qui nous protège et
stocke les réunions et pourquoi je les
ai jamais vus
et que tu ne vois rien
ne signifie pas qu'il n'y ait rien
plus tard humain un escargot qui parle
en fait je suis ni mars je n'ai pas de
coquilles ma belle mais qui êtes vous
nous sommes les hommes fument protecteur
de la forêt je ne suis pas de votre
monde qui t'arrive et à rapetisser mais
oui sérieux ça a été une journée bizarre
pour tout le monde il ya une raison pour
que tu sois ici parfois les connexions
de son tacle r je vais petit truire la
force
c'est notre monde meurt votre demande
moi aussi
viens tu es avec nous maintenant pas
à
aurait à partir à l'obscurité
il faudra d'abord nous affronter
dans le temps
tu peux pas aller plus vite ai-je fait
commenté suspendu à mon cerveau
il faut que je retrouve ma fille je suis
là regarde par ici
ausy n'ont pas le choix
vous ne pourrait arrêter le
pourrissement il est quoi le mall quoi